what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally covering infinity
or at least starting to cover infinity
this is a big story this is this is a
pretty huge story and it's amazing we're
gonna cover this and then book in into
Infinity Gauntlet part eight
Thanos quest parts one and two and then
the lead-up to Thanos quest so
technically we're kind of doing this out
of chronological order but infinity is
an amazing story it is it is such a
great story now this builds on
everything we've talked about so far
with Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers we kind of took a break from
that for a little while the idea of
Avengers and New Avengers is that a
dealt with the collapse of the
multiverse right the basically the end
of all thinks this is one of those
stories that leads up to that and it's
designed to kind of give us this
perspective that like everything's
popping off and everybody's really
panicking but initially what this does
is it actually picks up with Titan now
one thing I also want to preface here if
you are a little bit out of if you
haven't seen those videos what we always
fresh you guys as we go through this but
I would also suggest you guys go back
and watch those videos because it'll
it'll help to get you caught up on
everything that's going on right now but
we pick up on Titan and what we do is we
pick up with an out writer now out
riders are genetically modified or
really genetically engineered beings
that serve a singular purpose and that
purpose is whatever whims and wants
their masters want and so what we end up
doing is picking up with Corvus glaive
now right off the bat we're not told
this is Corvus glaive but we know
there's my virtue of the fact of how he
looks and really everybody's kind of
looked into him by now because of the
infinity war movie but what's really
happening is that this outrider shows up
and the questions asked where have you
been you know what what have you found
and the outright responds that it found
a place called up called al Ghul oh and
when the questions asked have you found
that gauntlet or is there a tribute what
this indicates is that things are being
hunted for in two fashions this group is
looking for the Infinity Gauntlet or
they're looking for a tribute if the
Infinity Gauntlet is not offered and so
what this thing basically says is there
is no gauntlet there but there is a
tribute that will be offered and so as a
result the outriders sent back out again
to find another world and so what we do
is we pick up on this planet a lagoon
with Corvus glaive himself this is what
I love about Jonathan Hickman riding is
basically like like word spreads when
these conquerors return word spreads of
Corvus glaive because river Corvus
glaive is hardcore now again this is
really like the first real appearance
that he has and notice this this guy is
so awesome he shows up at he asked the
questions where's Agha Lux the brave
you're you're brave
warrior where's this man that will save
you from the doom that I'm going to
bring to your doorstep and when the
question when those response given by
the king well we don't know Corvus
glaive simply says I know where he is I
know where he is because you sent him to
kill me as soon as we got here so not
only did I kill him I've destroyed his
sword which is a ceremonial weapon for
you oh and by the way here's the arm he
used to hold it with this is hard court
like they immediately summon the guards
right like the other King kind of freaks
out some of the guards chorus plays like
I think not you know and just like
that's not gonna happen at all and so in
response what is up happening what we
find out is that somewhere along the
line danos had shown up on this on this
world and just started like eradicating
people just sort of obliterating people
and put really push them to like the
brink of extinction and where there were
only a few thousand of them left what
they did is they rebuilt and so what the
alternative is a Corvus glaive offers a
really the ultimate Amira's is you can
give me a pittance or I will eradicate
what's left of your people and I will
destroy you in your entirety and so
ultimately they give in Corvus glaive
travels back to Titan he basically shows
stano's here's the tribute you're
looking for and we end up finding out
it's the heads of all the children that
existed on that planet and so at this
point we switch back to earth you
basically follow this outrider as it's
running through and as it's trying to
find what's going on I mean it goes from
place to place they can't see it it's
just jumping from person to person
trying to figure out what's going on and
trying to find this particular object
that is hunting for it now from here we
jump to another point in space and what
we have here are the builders the
gardeners in the ls now this is Jonathan
Hickman's way of retelling the origin of
the universe the issue with this is that
this is before Secret Wars in 2015 after
Secret Wars in 2015 the origin of the
universe was retold yet again by a guy
named Al Ewing in The Ultimates line of
comics would you'll find that video
video link down in the description but
basically before al viewing told his
origin what this essentially says is
that there's basically the builders they
are these beings that are responsible
for the creation of all things now again
we talked about this in the New Avengers
video that we did before but what
basically is established here is that
the builders created planets they
created life everything that exists
inside of this universe was created by
the builders they live up to their
namesake now again none of what we're
seeing here really applies anymore in
terms of the role the builders play that
origin is effectively kind of been wiped
away as far as we're aware they don't
really exist anymore so you can kind of
take this for what it's worth I mean the
role they play is still cool and it
still
matters in the confines of this story
but in the greater Marvel landscape it
doesn't really matter anymore so it's
just kind of left to whatever it is that
you want to follow here but the idea is
that on this world of the builders are
currently raising and destroying we have
what are called space Knights now the
space and ice made their appearances
back in 1979 with ROM number one and I
do not remember who wrote that story but
they are basically cyborgs there are not
full machines instead what you had was a
group called the Dyer race was we don't
willing to get into for this video but
the space Knights are basically does not
designed as this sort of interplanetary
slash galactic police force to a degree
but the idea is that they were basically
beings humanoid beings at one time that
were converted into these space Knights
and it's actually an honorable position
to take to offer yourself up and to be
accepted and become a space knight is
one of the highest honors that a
humanoid being can achieve in this part
of the universe but with them basically
being this more or less Avengers s kind
of super superhero team protecting this
world they're met by the arrival of
Captain universe now again this is all
part of that refresher stuff Captain
universe is it's really more of like a
concept that Bond's itself to a
particular person it's one of those
things where that the Kathleen universe
only ever really shows up when the
universe is in dire straits when the
universe is in danger there's some
massive threat that like Universal power
requires but the whole idea here is that
where you have a few days on this planet
to kind of say look the space Knights
are here this speights Knights are gonna
rescue us it makes sense because of
space Knights have for the most part
been undefeated it's like The Avengers
right like you have different members of
the Avengers have fallen but by and
large the larger Avengers roster has
always succeeded the heroes always win
and that's the point of this the really
the whole collapse of the multiverse
story is to answer the question what
happens when the heroes don't win and in
this small confined space that's what
kept the universe tells these these
people here like sure you can cheer on
the space Knights all you want to
they're going to die and so are you this
world is going to be destroyed and when
the question is why then the response is
because the builders are here and that's
when the builders say let it be as if
this planet never was and everything
gets destroyed the planets obliterated
innocent in its entirety and so what we
end up doing here is we transition to a
place called the peak with a group
called sword and now sword stands for
the sentient world observation and
response department and we've talked
about this a million times before where
shield exists to monitor earth
explicitly sword exists to monitor space
they basically monitor all these
different extraterrestrial races they
keep track of their radio chatter and
they basically keep an eye on things to
make sure that no one really
becomes a credible threat to earth but
if in situations like this an alien race
shows up on earth then sword takes
precedence over shield and the result is
that were sword initially sent in their
own agents to deal with this ultimately
they ended up pulling their agents out
and they brought the Avengers instead
and when the Avengers show up on the
scene we end up finding out this group
of people who were here our Scrolls now
again scrolls are shapeshifters that's
really kind of the big the big claim to
fame with them is they can take on the
form of virtually anything they want to
and where the avengers are able to put
them down relatively quickly they start
to notice that something isn't right
usually whatever the scrolls show up on
earth there-there is like a war group
designed to infiltrate the earth and
then try to take out humanity and take
over the earth
but we're Captain America and Hawkeye
and these various Avengers look around
what they start to realize is that if
this is not a war party and this is not
a scouting party they're not soldiers of
any kind
they look like refugees and if they're
refugees what are they fleeing from
that's the question that's being asked
yes that's the question they're trying
to find an answer to and so picking back
up with this outrider that basically
taken that that shows up on the city of
Attilan
as it goes through and starts to read
the mine a block bolt it digs further
and further into his past it digs
further and further into figuring out
what Black Bolt is about and this is
when we start to realize that what it's
looking for is the Infinity Gauntlet but
where it does find the Infinity stones
which were controlled and really
possessed by the Illuminati for quite
some time this is group that basically
had like a hidden hand inside the the
events that took place in Marvel Comics
what it also learns is the Infinity
stones have been destroyed now again
this dealt with the collapse of the
multiverse this dealt with the idea that
when you had worlds crashing into each
other basically another universe
crashing into the main Marvel Universe
the Illuminati's response was gathered
the Infinity Gauntlet you gather the
Infinity stones we can literally use the
power of our universe to push that
universe away but the Infinity stones
shattered the time stone disappeared and
the gauntlet is basically defunct now it
doesn't work anymore and that's what the
outrider realizes there are no more
Infinity stones left they're all gone
but then suddenly Black Bolt wakes up
says gatah my mind and then goes to
attack the outrider now where the
outrider tries to make its way out of a
till and cuts through a few people here
and there ultimately Black Bolt catches
up to it uses as quasi sonic scream to
try to disable it but it ultimately ends
up getting away and so the question is
what is this thing why is it here and
why is it looking for the Infinity
stones and so at this point we jump back
to the peak we jump back to Captain
America and all these guys and this is
cool because remember when it comes to
the Earth's superheroes for the most
part
usually our earth-based but what you
also have is a character named Smasher
now Smasher is an earthly but she's the
first earthling to be inducted into the
Shiar Imperial Guard now we talked about
this before the Shiar Empire is just a
an amalgamation of different races which
have all sworn fealty to like the
existing leader of the Shiar Empire but
with the Shiar Empire you have what's
called the Imperial Guard and the
Imperial Guard is basically some of the
hardest most intense and most capable
warriors that exist all across the face
of the universe and they're drawn from
like all different facets of the Shiar
Empire and even some are drawn from
beyond the Shiar Empire but they're
basically exceedingly capable and with
smasher being a part of the the Shiar
Imperial Guard that basically what she
says is your concerns are legitimate
well you're picking up all this radio
chatter and it's essentially every
single major empire that exists out
there in space that's recalling all of
its soldiers from every foreign battle
whether calling in every single ounce of
armed force they have the reason for
this is because something is mobilizing
in the universe that has the ability to
obliterate entire worlds the indication
here is that they're worried about the
builders the builders are going from
planet to planet blowing them up
destroying them in their entirety and
where the avengers try to get a hand on
things what we end up finding out is
that if the builders show up on earth
and there's no one there to stop them
they will annihilate the entirety of the
planet and every single superhero on
earth will die and so this is a
mobilization it's an attempt by Captain
America and Iron Man and Captain Marvel
Carol Danvers to basically rally all the
Avengers together and then send them out
in space for the purpose of trying to
take out these builders before they
arrive on earth the problem with this is
we pick back up with Titan and when we
pick up with Titan we end up having this
outrider who shows back up again and
basically gives all this information at
Corvus glaive who's also met with
Proxima midnight black dwarf the ebony
maw and supergiant basically the black
order and when this happens what we end
up finding out is that the Infinity
Gauntlet is gone the the the gauntlet
itself is on earth but the stones have
been destroyed everything except for the
time stone and Matt this planet can be
offered as a tribute the biggest caveat
to this and the biggest reason why this
is so important is that once we end up
having Corvus glaive make the
declaration and ask the question to
Thanos where do you want us to go Thanos
says we want to go to earth the various
people here respond because earth has a
reputation a lot of places hate earth
they despise earth but they also
recognize some of those powerful beings
in the universe
originate from Earth and so this is one
of those things where people look around
and they say the planet Earth is the
place where villains go to die like no
one ever goes there and comes out on top
the heroes always win if we go there
with nefarious schemes they will destroy
us and they will kill us and we'll just
be another notch in the belt but the
cool thing about this is a Corvus glaive
says under normal circumstances yes but
I've learned that there's discord in the
Inhumans oil family that the x-men are
are experiencing a schism Rimmer we
covered the schism event where Wolverine
and Cyclops basically experienced a rift
and they split apart and launched their
own x-men schools the earth is in
shambles in a variety of ways all this
comes out of civil war but the most
important thing to take away from all
this is that the Avengers have left
earth there are no Avengers on the
planet Earth it is ripe for the picking
now from here we jump to the really like
this of this massive battle that took
place between like the Avengers and the
various empires of the universe that
we're facing off against the builders
and this is kind of crazy because in
this particular battle that happened
like it was a massacre and it's
interesting because when the superhero
showed up when the various Avengers and
so on showed up they found like what
appeared to be a paltry fleet that
belonged to the to the builders and
maybe was one of those things of like
the builders had a weapon that was just
so powerful but if they destroy the ship
they destroy the weapon and all the
superheroes win and so for the most part
they kind of went into it with with
perceptions of guaranteed victory but
like the best laid plans of mice and men
what ended up happening is a ruse was
revealed that what the builders had done
as they had basically cloaked a majority
of their fleet and so once the
superheroes got in there and once they
were funneled into the hot gates and
they were boxed in the fleet was
decloaked and they were massacred and
the Avengers just like almost anybody
else who survived was just fleeing for
their life it was the only thing that
they could do now the other half of this
is that with Thanos being given word by
like Corvus glaive and so on that
basically the Infinity stones have been
lost and with the Kolob city and said
the only infinity stone thus left is a
time stone which vanished Thanos simply
said your job is to find it I will worry
about the Inhumans I will deal with them
and so again this is cool
because what is it happening is Corvus
glaive is initially sent to the Inhumans
but before we deal with before we jump
into that what we end up finding out is
that like the black order when they
showed up on earth they wrecked
everyone
the x-men done like those guys are
finished Atlantis was conquered by
Proxima midnight I'm sorry the ebony mom
this is one of the coolest things the
ebony maw is a really really powerful
sorcery the issue with this is that the
every mod really really relies more on
like duplicitous and duplicity and
manipulation and what are you done is he
had actually driven Doctor Strange to
summon Shu McGrath there were all these
things that went on but in Wakanda there
was a fighting chance because we're one
of the call obsidian showed up when
Wakanda
they were wrecked they were absolutely
devastated by Black Panther and the
wakandans which was so cool to see I was
like man this is absolute beast
there are comics that deal with this
these various skirmishes and so on but
essentially what went on here is that by
and large with the exception of like a
handful of places here and there
everybody had been taken out like
everybody had been defeated and there
really was no hope left for anybody else
earth had essentially fallen and so what
is up happening is we pick up with
Corvus glaive who shows up at the
inhuman Royal City now again this little
tidbit takes place before Thanos you
know heads out and goes to D with the
Inhumans themselves but Corvus glaive
shows up and immediately starts talking
trash he's like hey guys so I was told
there was a king here but I can't seem
to find that king maybe it's because
he's the king of a small tiny little
kingdom an itty bitty Kingdom that's
irrelevant maybe that's why I can't find
this king just like talking some serious
smack but it's interesting because
remember when it comes to Medusa and
Black Bolt Black Bolt can't really talk
he's got the quasi sonic scream so if he
were to like utter a word it has the
potential to destroy an entire planet so
as a result of this Medusa basically
speaks on his behalf
now Medusa is not a pushover she's not
someone to be trifled with and she
simply steps up and says hey look you
know you didn't come here to talk all
the trash all you want to just be aware
many have tried and many of failed so
you can come here to a-tellin and you
can make your threats but you may not
walk out of that you may not walk out of
this alive but here's the caveat to this
the Cole obsidian loves death they
worship death in the same way that
Thanos does and so for them being killed
is a welcoming thing if you really
believe that death is something that we
fear if you're so foolish as to believe
that didn't let me help you understand
your place in the bigger picture and in
turn like he has his soldiers cut their
own throats just to show that they have
no qualms with dying which means that
any and all control in each any type of
you know manipulation the Inhumans would
have had at their hands through
meaning them with death and so on that
it's all in vain there's nothing they
can do and so when when the question is
asked well then what do you want here
then Corvus glaive simply says a
pittance attribute the same thing he
said before but this is when we started
to find out what it is the question is
well what is the pittance and the
tribute that you want well then Corvis
play responds by saying we want the
heads of every child that exists inside
you're inhuman city between the ages of
16 and 22 now notice this this is
specific it's not just all the heads of
your kids
it's the heads of the kids between a
certain age which means that they're
looking for something but this is kind
of cool because what is up happening is
that like like Corvus glaive says look
you have an alternative here like you
you have a choice you can die a little
or you can die a lot you can sacrifice
the kids or we'll just come back and
kill everyone we've already taken down
virtually every single city that exists
all your superhero teams are in pieces
The Avengers are in space there's no one
left to challenge us so you can be the
last man standing and you could be the
last man to not make whatever choice you
want to make you have 24 hours and we're
going to come back and when we do there
has to be an answer and so what we end
up doing here it's picking back up with
really like the escaping members of the
Galactic Council
they're just fleeing for their lives
trying to get out of this this conflict
with the builders as fast as they can
and where they've all managed to make
their escape where they've all managed
to get away the remar shilling of forces
begins to come back into play again
because with the builders continuing to
be out there they have to be taken down
and the various superhero groups of
areas interplanetary governments and
interplanetary soldiers and teams and so
on and so forth
are all functioning as part of a unified
front to try to take these guys down
they find small successes here and there
and taking out like different factions
of the builders armies but at the end of
the day it doesn't matter because what
ends up happening is the gardener
actually he like just kind of takes off
the end of the planet and just kind of
sacrifices his life but the result is
that in doing so with the destruction of
one of these beings what is happening is
like the entire planet is basically sent
into a state of decay and disease
meaning those individuals who are left
behind those who are stuck here on this
planet men women and children alike they
all just succumb to illness and disease
and death they literally just exist in
this terrible circumstance of
destruction and so what ends up
happening is you end up having Black
Bolt who basically summons the rest of
the Illuminati Black Panther dr. strange
Reed Richards name of the Submariner
iron man and beast breeds them all
together and essentially says like
here's what's going on Thanos is on
earth right now like while you guys are
out there fighting this battle in space
Thanos is on earth and
is invading Earth but Thanos is looking
for something particular he's looking
for one thing and when the questions
asked what is that black bolts like look
I'll deal with him on my own
I'll deal with deadly I'll give him my
answer in my city by myself but like
what he's looking for is his son that's
why he's here
Thanos is looking for his son so he can
kill him with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain it make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace